[Música]
e essa questão de pós modernidade é um
problema se o que define pós modernidade
tem mais de 1.000 definições eu não
pretendo me arriscar nisso né
pretendo apenas simplificar bastante e
dizer que a pós modernidade é impactadas
pela questão da tecnologia da informação
e o seu produto mais notável embora não
seja o único que a internet o mundo se
divide entre aqueles que como eu
nasceram antes da internet e os que
nasceram depois da internet
então agora recentemente estava na moda
história desafio dos dez anos resolvi
botar o desafio dos 30 anos porque é
mais condizente com a minha idade né
então aqui o meu pai muito esforçado que
saudade que eu tenho disso comprou o
barça a mineradora britânica e outras
que já consigo me lembrar o nome a borra
neojibá wikipedia pra todo mundo
ah eu né já estava cansada de ficar
escutando gil caetano caetano gil achava
bacana continuo achando muito legal mas
eu tava a fim de escutar rock né eu saía
de casa pegava o ônibus e até a wifi
records e comprava um lp né cabo e aliás
hoje gil e caetano e os roqueiros como
ultraje a rigor convivem pacificamente
no spotify como eles não convivem na
vida real
mas enfim mais um detalhe da
pós-modernidade eu ia ao cinema eu
continuo indo ao cinema eu acho legal
mas eu lembro da gente ficar esperando
com ansiedade um filme depois ficar
aflito porque se eventualmente perder se
o filme saiu de cartaz
bom hoje os eua estão todos ali à mão de
quem quiser né
nós vivemos por assim dizer a era da
abundância em todos os sentidos em todos
os sentidos e isso devia ser bom isso
deveria ser muito bom
interessantemente às vezes não é isso
tem impacto na nossa socialização a
forma como ele se relaciona uns com os
outros
então aqui já não é mais um desafio dos
30 anos é o desafio dos 40 anos esse
carinha magrela aqui sou eu
desculpe a falta de definição da foto né
nós cada vez mais é ou as utilizamos -
dessa forma e agora a gente socializa
assim né ah mas isso é muito
interessante ver como isso tem impacto
na forma como você socialista falar com
você se relaciona com a sociedade porque
tem estudos na tentando é dimensional
assim o tamanho do cérebro porque é que
na nossa espécie o cérebro cresceu tanto
que nosso cérebro cresceu para a gente
poder por um homem na lua não foi isso
nosso cérebro cresceu ea gente põe um
homem na lua a gente faz coisas
incríveis mas isso é um efeito colateral
o principal objetivo do crescimento do
cérebro era aumentar nossa capacidade de
socialização de cooperação mútua
bom então esses cientistas eles avaliar
o tamanho do cérebro de vários animais
sociais sobretudo de primatas
então o primata mais próximo da gente um
chimpanzé sabe grupos maiores grupos do
tipo sexo tem relato na altura sabe qual
o tamanho 60 e quem estivesse achando
que está muito acima do chimpanzé pode
esquecer nossa arma um pouquinho mais
equipado que o de então segundo as
projeções o número máximo de relações
sociais estáveis possíveis de serem
convenientemente manchadas pelo seu
cérebro o seu o meu 150 e agora a
pergunta que não quer calar
quantos amigos você disse que você tinha
no facebook certamente o mais modesto
que se tiver um facebook tem mais do que
150 e isso tem já reflexos desde 2015
foi primeiras turmas seguiram se outros
né esse é um estudo feito na dinamarca
onde propuseram se você pegar 12 mil
usuários mil continuavam usando a rede
social foram como normalmente usava e
mil foram convidados a ficar um mês
distante da rede social
um mês após o grupo que ficou sem o uso
da rede social estava mais feliz tinha
mais bem estar subjetivo pelo simples
fato e que parou de usar a rede por 30
dias
meu deus o que está acontecendo é o que
também se chama nessa nova a modalidade
de de pesquisa chance o ciber
comportamento assim psicologia
kristiansund som show overload ou
sobrecarga social é traduzindo em miúdos
veja se isso já aconteceu com você
você fica tenso se sentindo há
literalmente soterrado debaixo tantos e
mails achando que meu deus recebi sem
meios hoje responde 30 que você conhecer
70 ao mês chegar mas sim eu sou
respondesse 30 e faça uma conta 70 e
mesmo responde a cada dia depois de 30
dias não tenho dois mil e cem e mails
que eu não respondi sem contar as
mensagens mais exato sem contar os a aaa
os as mensagens que recebo de coisas
interessantes que sair no youtube e
tetra eu estou perdendo alguma coisa é o
famoso medo de ficar de fora ou que lhe
chama the missing out
a contrapartida é que de repente você é
tomado por um desejo e inexplicável de
apagar tudo isso e ficar longe dessas
redes por um tempo e eu recomendo que se
você está sentindo isso faça isso né
ah não é justo dizer que é só o facebook
então esse estudo aqui foi o estudo
feito pela sociedade é real britânica de
saúde pública
então eles mediram conteúdos positivos e
conteúdos negativos com um conteúdo
positivo na opiniões dicas sobre saúde
opinião do expert suporte emocional e
auxílio à construção de relacionamentos
conteúdo negativo muita ênfase imagem
corporal muita site promovendo
comportamentos francamente é é a 2 como
anorexia nervosa bulimia nervosa muito
prática de bullying de cyber bullying é
de intimidação através da internet e
esse medo constante de ficar de fora o
famoso missing out tudo isso tem uma
correlação direta com os níveis de
sintomas expressadas de ansiedade e de
depressão certo
vejam aqui que não olha de acordo com
esse estudo o instagram tá mandando
muito mal é o pior de todos seguindo
pelo snec chat o facebook pegou um
modesto terceiro lugar
o twitter vai segundo o youtube porém
que foi esse o único conseguiu passar o
limiar do equilíbrio emocional
evidentemente que esse é um estudo
apenas isso precisa continuar sendo
replicado mas que é um fato estabelecido
é a mídia social não está fazendo bem
para sua saúde emocional como disse é
tudo isso é fruto dessa abundância
incrível
você pode comer assim se quiser hoje né
vá até uma churrascaria e por um preço
que acontecesse consideraria até que
acessível você pode comer uma variedade
de alimentos que vou dizer pra vocês
luís 14 o rei sol não tinha acesso a
tanto alimento pelo menos não uma única
refeição né isso não falar o número de
sapatos lembra maria antonieta que ela
foi decapitado entre outras coisas por
que comprar sapatos demais que mandou o
povo como yoshi no lugar de pão e redes
extra muito bem vocês aí tem mais
sapatos já tiveram mais sapatos do que
maria antonieta é a era da abundância da
abundância e da tecnologia tecnologia
combinada que produz essa abundância mas
que também produz alguns produtos
estranhos isto aqui é muito estranho
isso aqui é muito estranho isso aqui é
delicioso né porque porque isso aqui é
amarelinho é crocante tinho esses
grãozinhos de sal
o interior é quente e úmido
são todos elementos que apela a
palatabilidade eles ocorrem nos
alimentos naturais mas não ocorre junto
ao mesmo tempo uma coisa só
então isso aqui foi feito para você
perder o controle isso aqui pode ter
gente que eu não gosto tanto assim mas
esse serviço e corre corre há a come lá
ninguém sai de casa pra comer brócolis
pra comer couve um chuto que o voto no
restaurante pediu uma couve flor já viu
alguém fazer isso mas se diz vilma manda
conversar comigo estou interessada disso
as pessoas saem de casa pra isso daqui
assim hoje eu tô com vontade naquele
lugar ou pedir uma torta de chocolate um
bolo brown não sei lá o que isso é
é bom eu sei que é bom né mas não é só a
alimentação quer dizer a epidemia de
obesidade é um fato mas a aas
possibilidade né até de certa forma
desenfreada de crédito as oportunidades
de consumo e de um lazer que muitas
vezes não é exatamente o mais saudável a
visto que então cria-se um novo problema
que a pós modernidade
é é a era da adicção somos todos adictos
em algum nível aqui certo e aí o grande
lance é só parar de fumar facinho eu já
fiz isso 5 vez né
o problema é continuar parado ou em
outras palavras o problema é evitar a
reincidência
sim nós já sabemos psicólogos médicos
psiquiatras já sabe como ajudar as
pessoas a pararem a gente ainda continua
embatucado essa coisa do ajuda o cara
continua parado e esse todo o problema
não é só ficar parado né
ele vai deixar de fazer alguma coisa ele
precisa adotar um outro estilo de vida
um estilo de vida que tenha qualidade de
vida e aí é onde a gente começa a passar
por um território muito pouco explorado
médicos psicólogos também são muito bons
em apontar para você as raízes da sua
infelicidade
onde estão as raízes da sua felicidade
vou te dar uma dica não estão no mesmo
lugar o remédio que suprime a tristeza
não promove felicidade
o remédio que suprime a ansiedade não
promove bem estar e serenidade
isso é uma outra prescrição meus amigos
e não é uma prescrição farmacológica
bom eu tô falando disso porque assim a
questão do bem-estar subjetivo se
preferirem pura e simplesmente
felicidade é fundamental tão fundamental
que se você tivesse não deveria sair de
casa sem a a medida em que a gente
avança tens avanços tecnológicos
a gente venceu as doenças infecciosas a
gente venceu a desnutrição certo e aí
outras doenças e aparelhos apresentam
como desafio como por exemplo as doenças
cardiovasculares a doença o câncer ea
doença mental o sofrimento mental
bom me desculpe aqui mas felicidade é
tão correta que ela dá uma cacetada nas
três coisas ao mesmo tempo né quem é
mais feliz sabidamente está mais
protegido com transtorno mental
quem tem menos sofrimento emocional quem
é mais feliz tem menos a está mais
protegido contra o câncer doença
cardiovascular e diabetes em última
análise tem mais expectativa de vida com
ç ã
mais qualidade ops então isso não
deveria estar na prescrição
o profissional de saúde quando você vai
lá ele vai pra você não faça isso não
faça aquilo e faça mais isso mas isso
mais aquilo pra você poder ver melhor
mais e melhor né
bom vamos começar eu não tenho aqui uma
fórmula pronta nós vamos começar por
algumas coisas que é importante lembrar
vamos evitar as armadilhas primeira
armadilha as pessoas trocam dinheiro por
tempo então senti eu quero uma promoção
então tudo bem esses meses agora daqui
até junho eu vou trabalhar inclusive nos
fins de semana eu vou é me precaver de
conviver com as pessoas que eu amo
porque eu vou ter com a promoção eu vou
ter um salário melhor e eu vou poder é
ter mais qualidade
ledo engano primeiro censo segue essa
promoção e se você essa promoção você
vai trabalhar mais ainda né
as pessoas também estão o tempo inteiro
trocando prestígio por conforto né
quero morar numa cobertura na avenida
paulista legal já deu uma olhada quanto
custa esse condomínio que a pessoa
quanto você paga para poder viver lá né
e se você fosse viver num apartamento de
50 metros quadrados naquele por juca
pode dizer que talvez fosse igualmente
feliz quem sabe mais porque menos stress
significa mais felicidade
aliás a fórmula da felicidade como essa
são coisas muito simples
por favor todos aqui vão dormir bem hoje
tá se não estão dormindo bem discutir
uma forma de dormir bem procure um
médico pensa que tá tirando seu sono
tem sim que se alimentar bem é um fato e
tem que socializar é indispensável ter
um estudo inclusive um outro tédio né
que é o seguinte é é a socialização faz
mais bem o seu coração do exercício
físico
a nota não dizendo não faz exercício
físico o abraça uma vida sedentária mas
todos tinham aquelas situações todas
aquelas situações de situação forçada né
de escolha o cliente pode escolher força
a gente acha que não acontece mas
acontece
eu tô no piauí está super legal tô super
gostoso e eu tenho que sair mais cedo
porque eu tenho treino marcado sabe que
vai fazer mais bem o seu coração perder
aquele treino
o rebelde gostoso fica se diverte relaxa
faça o bem aos outros recebam bem os
outros também
e depois por favor vai fazer um pouco de
ginástica também mas você tem sábado
domingo os horários para fazer isso
certo não precisa ser na hora da
diversão com os amigos
bom se eu falei de socialização então
agora voltar o começo na minha fala que
é as tais das redes sociais essa estavam
trazendo tanta infelicidade elas
precisam de um novo papel
as críticas a gente já conhece mas
atualmente estimam demais narcisismo a
competição a intolerância e para algumas
pessoas ela perigosamente se candidata a
ser um substituto ruim da interação face
a face
o que a gente gostaria de ver essas
redes realmente praticarem essas redes
precisam ser mais lúdicas o lúdico é
importante eu defender aqui que essas
redes têm um certo elemento de game
ficação que você entra numa rede e ganhe
pontos por conhecer alguém mas não
vencer
você marcou encontro encontro é quando
esse encontro vocês dão um cheque no seu
baú de parte a parte e ganhou ponto se
encontra o número maior de pessoas
ganhou ponto faz isso regularmente
ganhou sim nós somos movidos por essa
dinâmica zinha meio bes tinha mas que
tanto nos ajuda porque não só isso em
nosso favor né
se tem uma coisa que engajam ante é
participar de jogos
a outra coisa essas redes elas poderiam
estimular mais o modo gregário e
solidário das pessoas então a vez
daqueles aqueles há aqueles aplicativos
que diz assim você correu tanto no
percurso tal você está em sétimo lugar
no ranking de um fundo que fulano bateu
o seu recorde sai lá agora e ganha dele
porque o horror né e só vai desestimular
as pessoas que não têm necessariamente
tinham atlética que tal você ganha
pontos por que você saiu levou um amigo
com você
certo a as redes precisam ter e aí vou
retirar os pêlos dos libertários mas as
redes precisam ter um código interno de
conduta permitindo dessa forma um debate
aberto né mais tolerante
esse negócio a gente ficasse fechando um
clubinho e só repercutir o discurso um
do outro porque ele concorda comigo eu
concordo com ele não vai nos levar a
lugar nenhum e finalmente essas redes
podem ajudar né
é juntando a demanda ea oferta né há
exemplos incipientes mas são bons
exemplos são os sites de transporte e de
paquera que estão fazendo sucesso
adoidado porque em algum lugar tem
alguém que é uma carona e outro lugar
tem alguém que pode dar essa carona
certo
ah ah ah finalmente uma utilidade real
para as redes sociais muito bem mas que
tal mais do que isso vamos adiante que
tal uma rede que estimula atividades da
seguinte maneira eu sempre quis sempre
foi apaixonado pela idéia de fazer quem
dom ou que jutsu para quem não conhece é
a esgrima samurai onde raios eu vou
encontrar um professor de que 2 c que
existe são paulo ele existe mas ele
treina e trabalha há 30 quilômetros na
minha casa e se eu fosse pagar pra ele
vir até mim e isso provavelmente não ia
ser muito custo efetivo mas essa rede a
gente poderia por exemplo entrar nessa
rede que ainda nem existe eu digo assim
eu sou maluco eu gosto de queijo tzu
quem mais gosta que nem eu descobri que
tem mais cinco caras no meu bairro que
koston já se tornou economicamente
viável trazer um professor e assim vale
não só para quem junto mas pra
fotografia para a história da arte
filosofia moral que qual seja a loucura
que você né e cultiva dentro de você
meditação meditação só faz crescer só
fazem só faz crescer o número de estudos
que mostram os benefícios da meditação é
difícil começar sozinho é difícil de se
motivar uma rede que estimule isso a
congregar pessoas para uma prática mais
coletiva pode ajudar bastante nesse
sentido
enfim nós queremos uma rede que não faz
só essas coisas mas que estimula e
aproximar as pessoas da arte e da
cultura porque está intimamente
vinculado à qualidade de vida né então é
isso quer dizer ah ah ah tecnologia
sobre o setor da mídia de informação ela
é tão somente o instrumento se nós vamos
ter uma atitude irreverente e um tanto
quanto é cega em relação a uso dessa
tecnologia né
se nós vamos nos deixar escravizar por
ela
isso é tão somente culpa nossa
o instrumento não pode ser culpado pelo
uso
a gente faz dele nós somos os
responsáveis e também não também é nossa
responsabilidade fazer um uso que nos
traga o futuro melhor
é isso
[Aplausos]